hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have a treat for you
in the form of one of the best speakers
i've
tested since i started testing speakers
um it's the genelec 8361a
it's a powered three-way studio monitor
but many people buy these also for home
listening or building home theaters and
this one is extremely suitable for that
it's a
typical of the uh newer generation of
general genelecs with this uh coaxial
driver in here and then it has
underneath this uh a baffle you have
dual oval uh woofers in here
and then there's a port in the back
um
that look is not for everyone i used to
not like it but it's sort of grown on me
uh now and
but you know it's polarizing uh from
that point of view in a professional
setting would be great but in home use
you have to decide whether uh you know
you can tolerate something that doesn't
look like a piece of furniture
uh on this um it's like a giant
bookshelf speaker but it weighs as much
as many tower speakers floor standing
speakers it weighs about 70 pounds so
it's a two person lift and carry uh it's
extremely dense uh case i think uh you'd
have a cast aluminum
and uh
it is very very stout it feels like you
could run over it with a tank and uh
he'll still survive
uh on this thing there's a single strap
in the back to lift it
unfortunately it's not enough when you
grab it with the flexible strap that's
in the back it will just tilt over or
become like a suitcase and then you're
carrying 70 pounds with one arm away
from you so not a very easy thing to
move around you need two people uh to
move it um because it was so heavy i
also didn't take a picture of it in the
back uh but you have a suite of inputs
obviously balanced input
but you also have digital inputs and it
supports the glm which is the
application that the genelec has for uh
automatically or manually setting
parametric eqs and target curves for the
speaker
and if you buy their kit you're able to
do the room analysis automatically and
then modify as you see fit
um so with that intro you can read more
about it elsewhere uh typical of my
reviews on focus on performance not as
much
features and what have you
um
our most important graph is the
spinorama
or the cea-2034 standard
set of frequency response measurements
most important one is the on axis
response which is this black line in
here
and as you see in here for speaker this
is very very flat um
there's a little bit of a step down in
base frequencies but genelec's own
measurements doesn't show this and i'm
communicating with them to try to find
out whether that's a measurement
difference between us or what the cause
might be uh so that this in another one
of the general-like speakers also so
something needs to be resolved but you
know it's just one or two db difference
and something that easily can be
adjusted
on this thing it's really just the base
drivers the rest of them are very flat
um
the directivity is great and we can tell
that by comparing the on
to this blue one which is the important
reflections and we see that the two have
very equal gap between them and that's
shown down here as also a difference
between them so it's a very very nice
measurement from that point of view
one thing that's super impressive is the
how deep the frequency response goes
this is 30 hairs over here and it's
essentially flat to 30 hertz over here
you want to follow the dashed red line
which is the total sound power that
includes the portal that's in the back
and so that's basically within shouting
distance of of 30 hertz and if you put
it in room likely this this will tilt
even higher uh because of the um room
loading that you get
um
uh the uh
ca2034 also a stipulate set of
reflections which is valid for uh
far-field listening or regular home
music listening uh not as much for
studio monitor listening near field but
it's close enough um if i draw a line in
here on the sum of the reflections
because the directivity is good
that means the
this line is also very much matches the
the response which is what we want to
see we don't want to see variations up
and down we want to see smooth what this
also says is that you can put the
speaker in many rooms and it'll sound
good it's not room dependent because all
the reflections have similar tonality to
on axis
so the uh resp you know the tonality
doesn't change the base response will
change if you put in different rooms but
that's happens with every speaker so
that's one of the nice things the second
nice thing is that when you have this
kind of nice directivity you can also
equalize the speaker
very easily and know that both on and
off axis change together
if the on and off axis are not the same
then make an unique equalization change
will change the on axis and and off axis
differently and so you can't correct off
axis errors with eq whereas now you can
because the two are very similar
um we can put the last two graphs
together and
build the composite that predicts what
the response would be in a room and
generally want to tilt it down response
and because that sounds flat to us if
you want measured
tilted down but that's objective will
sound flat and this is exceptionally
good it's basically as good as it gets
uh you know an ideal one will look like
that line but you know little wiggles in
there here and there it's just nature of
a mechanical device trying to produce a
frequency response so extremely good
one of the problems with the ported
speakers in about 90 speakers i test is
that at some point um the wavelength of
the sound uh matches uh half a quarter
of the distance between vertical
horizontal distances of the enclosure
and that causes a resonance so literally
the the box starts to amplify things and
when you have a port the uh sound comes
out of the port and radiates as if it's
a mid-range speaker and here we see that
usually when i measure the port by
itself as i've done here in brown
and this is the output of the port which
is what we want and then we see that the
response just drops like a rock it then
resonates up a little bit but it's way
down from the
output of the woofer and the mid-range
so this is less than one percent in
interference with respect to the levels
here and that means that it's basically
not contributing anything and the fact
that it's pointed backwards means it's
got to bounce off the wall and come back
or radiate around so it loses some
amplitude there
in addition to that so this is not easy
to do requires very very good design
like i said eighty percent of the
speakers i test these peaks in here are
way up here uh and that's unfortunate
when they're also doing the crossover
region so clearly some smart design has
gone into here
the other smart design is what we expect
from company like genelec is this very
smooth directivity so if we
uh plot what happens uh you know where
sound level drops by 6 db
uh you know per frequency in here we see
that it's wide as it normally is where
the woofers are omnidirectional always
and then when it starts to get narrow it
then gets very controlled and stays flat
and smooth in here which is very very
good characteristics it means all
frequencies again are hitting the walls
equally and reflecting back at you uh
you don't get some frequencies higher
than the others
and if using this near field means when
you're moving around your tonality is
not shifting um the other nice thing is
that these other curves are at more uh
of attenuation
are also very similar to this and you
can see in here how these graphs
are so nice together
this gets messed up if there are
diffractions and other things where the
sound goes around the corners if the
corners are sharp uh you get the little
tiny speakers everywhere interfering
with each other and
you get irregularity in here the
the speakers got just massive wave guide
and it's really smooth edges and
everything really helps with that and
you can see this that same output when
we plot it as a sort of a
contour map uh we can see this is a very
controlled uh this is think about this
as the 60b line i was showing you but
look how smooth the graduations are and
it doesn't really get messy to get way
very
lower amplitudes in here but the gra you
know the shift from the strongest to the
weakest sound is very very smooth
one thing coaxial drivers give you is
that their vertical directivity is
almost as good as their horizontal
directivity a typical woofer and a
twitter two-way speakers don't do this
they're
horizontally that axis is aligned
between the woofer and the mid-range or
twitter but vertically they're separated
and as you go up and down the timing
changes and you get a
response that's not very uh unified here
we have one big coaxial driver in the
middle so it doesn't care if you go
vertical or go in horizontal and you get
the same smooth grab with what this
means is you can take the speaker and
rotate it on the side indeed comes with
a different mount for using it that way
and you get a center speaker out of it
uh that's completely matched with your
left and right so if you want to use it
for that application it's great or you
know in your studio you may want to have
these horizontally placed because that
way the
you know the center might be lower for
you or it may look more pleasing
the
clippable near field scanner is able to
completely compute the
3d sound sphere at any frequency than
any point in space so i've started to
tell it to
plot three different frequencies one
killers two colors and three kilohertz
uh these are where our hearing is most
sensitive and
we look at the geometry of the the
waveform from the speaker as it's
expanding and
his color-coded again red means the
strongest loudest and and green and blue
means least loud the wavefront in the
front is is the most important thing and
we can see at one kilohertz it's just
this gorgeous sphere that's just coming
out you're fully uniform expanding in
space um a little bit more wiggly at two
kilohertz it's probably the two woofers
uh getting a little stronger in here but
then they settle down and we're back to
a very very smooth uh uh radiation
pattern if you look at some others cheap
budget speakers they're not well
implemented you see all kinds of twisted
shapes in in here and that means that
the sound that's going up uh hitting the
ceiling coming down has different
tonality of the sound that comes at you
or if you move up and down a little bit
or left and right sound will vary this
is basically textbook perfect uh
uh on this thing
um
as far as distortion this is incredibly
powerful speaker i think the woofer has
700 watts of class d amplification alone
and uh when i tested ad6db spl i'm
listening in my measurement room with
with
heavy-duty ear protection even through
those i could just hear this smooth
beautiful sweep from very low
frequencies all the way up and
this is 86 db at one meter
always also measure at 10 db higher and
it's still excellent a lot of the
speakers are measured this distortion
will actually shoot up as high as the
sound you're hearing and when you do
that you get about 100 distortion so
this is way way below that is extremely
clean
speakers go but i wanted to push this is
such a big speaker so i uh pushed it
even 10 dbr so now we're at 160b spl
now the clipping light came on and
the frequency response drops uh in the
treble region which is what i've seen
the protection circuit do and
in general x it's a compressor really
and pulls back the treble trying to save
that so they probably have experience
knowing that that's you know that's the
part that's stressed the most not the
woofers we still haven't hit 100
distortion which again many speakers do
uh on this thing so still very very
controlled so and i'll talk about my
subjective experience later on but
distortion is just not in your
vocabulary when you're using this 8361
this is the waterfall display i've
actually tweaked a little bit um and
hence the reason it's kind of looking
smooth up here i'm not sure i'm a fan of
that i may go back to the way i was
showing it before it shows a number of
resonances but it always does that and
if i just change one of the parameters
down here which is the floor by just one
or two db a lot of these disappear
and i play with it and every time i post
this it's really not a useful graph
unless you're just troubleshooting
something and you want to confirm
something in general every one of these
uh
you know time domain extensions actually
correspond to a peak over here and you
can see them over here with these larger
ones that they're basically correlated
anyway so if you just look at the
frequency response every place there's a
little wiggle up and down there will be
one of these um what are the causes
could be anything slight resonances in
the enclosure the drivers or even the
fixture i have this this is sitting on
top of my robotic measurement system and
you can literally shake and resonate the
the measurement system so don't go nuts
looking analyzing this waterfall people
love it because it looks fancy and
beautiful but it really not very
informative i also don't usually post
the impulse response but in this case i
did because it just looked very
idealized and very smooth it just has a
single pulse and it's done
usually multiple drivers you know the
faster the treble comes first and then
the mid-range and then the woofer will
have a large uh you know extension here
i was surprised at how they all
basically timeline
and uh show up pretty uh
you know what the audibility impact of
that is i don't know it certainly is
there's nothing wrong with having to be
better than
we tolerate uh and this is definitely
the case
so the the next test in here is a
listening test i always listen um
you know
you've heard me explain what these
graphs mean but ultimately there are
some subtleties that i can't quantify in
these tests
and
with this uh um 8361
a as soon as i played it it just was
incredibly nice sounding with a tiny
caveat that it just sounded a little
light which i expect
studio monitors to do there tend to be
more flatter response than the hi-fi
speakers
i'm very sensitive to high frequency
exaggeration or distortion and it was
nothing remotely like that but seeing
that the the base was down one or two db
i put a shelving filter in there that
just took the base and
flatly moved it up
a couple of db when i did that on some
tracks it just made an amazing
difference in amount of sub bass that it
brought out but it got a little boomy
and i know that at 105 hertz i have a
room mode that exaggerates things so in
reality there's a peak and a response in
my room that shouldn't be there so from
experience i just dialed 2 db down in
here and pulled that down
once i did that it was just amazing
amazing amazing i've never heard the
power monitor
have this kind of dynamics this kind of
power and this kind of deep bass i mean
you do not for a second wish you had a
subwoofer not only is there sub-bass uh
content
spinning out of the speaker
it does it in the most uniform
integrated way possible i mean i've had
subs that were incredibly well well
integrated with the system and still
once in a while i would go in there and
turn the level down a little bottom 2 db
and during the backup depending what i'm
playing
it's just you know getting two
curves to match it's hard when you buy a
subwoofer for one company and speaker
from another company then you put in a
room that messes with both of them
getting the two to align and work
perfectly all the time is very hard this
one was just perfect i mean i just had
no need to want to get us up with her
nor thinking for a moment that it was
something wrong with the with the
integration of it it just sounded like
beautiful sub bass coming down to 25 30
hertz
and
you know while the speaker you could
localize the sound the bass would just
as it normally is it just would emanate
out of this thing and i keep saying
that's not possible it's not possible
the speaker is like a chunky
large bookshelf speaker but this
beautiful beautiful you know sub basis
it's just coming out of the speaker
and it was bringing out the extension
that i've never ever heard in any other
speaker i've tested my own reverse salon
twos can reproduce them but you know
everything else i test them they just
ignore and roll off all these lows this
thing just goes way deep despite
boosting a 2db i could turn it up turn
it up turn it up till the entire house
wants to come down and and i'm testing
it in this massive large open space
it had no trouble filling this room with
just a single speaker which i test so if
you have two of them
i mean sky is definitely the limit as
far as the level of loudness and
dynamics you could get out of the
speaker tonality never changes
distortion never enters the equation
what can i say is the most perfect
speaker i've tested so far and
it's just lusciously good uh it's five
thousand dollars for a speaker so it's
not cheap but if you think about the
fact that you have three amplifiers in
there as digital the analog converter
has a dsb in there for
me applying eq applying room correction
you know trying to build the system with
you know over a thousand watts of
amplification and three-way and then
build the crossover all this stuff i
think you it won't be possible for you
to do to build it as good or better than
this speaker and i'm not sure you ever
need to spend more than just five
thousand dollars to get anything else i
mean
the only thing it doesn't do is it
doesn't portray a massive wall of sound
which you can get with with the pla you
know plane or electrostatic speakers and
and large tower speakers like my revel
salon twos those are you know a vertical
column of sound so
when a singer sings you literally have a
scale that's the size of a singer
this the scale is medium so it's
compressed down some so
maybe for large orchestral music a big
band you know a massive set of speakers
that would cost you ten times more than
the speaker uh
maybe more suitable
but
you know if you step down from that and
say you know i want a more compact
speaker and i don't want to spend a
fortune you know on this thing and
this is incredible i mean i have a
passion and soft spot for jbl's and
revels and
i can't recommend any of them
instead of this unless you want the
attributes that i just talked about
and i think this blows many of those
away in in other characteristics so
you know it's the highest praise i can
provide for this the speaker was sent by
a member not the company by the way the
company is very supportive one of the
few companies that listens to me i send
them measurements they give feedback
they're on the forum and
so from that point of view they're very
supportive but this is not a golden
sample or anything this was a speaker
that was picked and by member but and
anonymously and sent to me for testing
so you know if you you know i don't like
the term in-game but uh if you want to
put a stake in the ground say one day i
will have speakers that that's just
beyond the shadow doubt
is gonna sound wonderful
uh is this is it so you wanna put five
thousand dollars per speaker in the
ground and say
okay well i know the day i can afford
ten thousand dollars for two of these
you know i'm done uh no i guess out of
hand with with the home theater with you
know five channels of these things but
maybe if you buy five of them uh pro
dealer will will discount them for you
so yeah for home theater it gets to be
too much but you don't need this this
speaker in the backs and the other
channel uh three of them in the front
would be nice she's still looking at
fifteen thousand dollars but uh you know
that decision you've gotta make but from
my point of view uh this this speaker
you know makes a quantum leap forward
from all the other speakers i've tested
including other general likes the other
channel likes
many of them sound wonderful because
they have similar kind of measurements
but i crank it up and that
the clipping light comes on and then the
sound the limiter kicks in there's
static there's pullbacks especially if
you go to small ones
and for me none of those are real
targets because you know i don't want to
have technology to tell me what it can't
do
i want that limitation to be me which is
how loud i want to listen
and enjoy i want the technology to have
that much headroom pass where i want to
be so i never know about the limit
that's why using a thousand watt
amplifiers not that i ever pump a
thousand watts but i know that at the
levels i listen to the amplifier is
never the limit
and this is the first powered speaker
that
i see that it has like way past headroom
that i want with an extension and base
that subwoofer class extension
i just haven't seen it there uh
lower end jbl's do well as far as
getting loud and so forth also but
they're again not in this class
then again they're half third of
the price so you decide um so if the
looks of the speaker are not a problem
for you and uh
the uh price is not an issue
this is really really great speaker and
this is not a random subjective review
as you can tell stuff that i'm talking
about it's backed by measurements
so maybe you don't like the tonality
well great user tools and change the eq
if you want a little bit less trouble
you can tilt it down more bass like i
needed
you can boost that up so it's fully
programmable anyway so as far as i'm
concerned there's no excuse to
you know say well something wrong with
this well if you say something wrong you
better come back with very strong
evidence because there's just none that
i can put my finger on it everything is
executed perfectly and then there's
ample amount of power and dynamics and
extension in low frequencies so
uh
summarizing is the best speaker i've
tested so far
and one that finally rivals my own
everyday speakers which cost twenty
three thousand dollars for a pair by the
way for noah but no amplification uh my
ravels want to so
uh
to put a smile on my face a brand like
this it's just it takes a lot and and
the channel like
8361a gets there so if you can afford it
uh
run and get one and start enjoying the
sound okay hopefully uh you like this
review and uh see you in a future video
bye-bye